what happened exactly without because
it's somewhat of a sensitive topic um on
on youtube and things like that but you
were in a contest and then
it was someone that was a transgender
woman who was a biological man compete
in the contest and won first place
that's right i got second place and then
what what happened well i didn't speak
up about it right away because i didn't
know
how to handle it and i didn't want to
i wanted to just enjoy the contest and
skate like normal and i tried to just be
a good sword about it but
the more that i thought about it the
more i realized how unfair it was and
how wrong it was and i thought
i should reach out to red bull so i
emailed eric at red bull
and it was it was a polite email i just
said hey i have some concerns about this
being unfair i'm not sure if you're the
right person to talk to about it but i'm
sure you can direct me to the right
person and we'd emailed before he'd
always got back to me it wasn't like i
just like emailed customer service and
and like hoped i would hear something
hope that's in one of the cars with a
big red bull can on top to pick you up
right no it was like the guy who was
organizing all the stuff for um the
contest after i had qualified in
michigan and
he just never responded
so
for a while i just tried to ignore it
and i had
shared the story of what had happened
with i'd say hundreds of skaters because
it had been like four or five months and
everybody was just like oh my gosh i'm
sorry that happened and
seeing everyone's reaction to it kind of
validated the way i was feeling
and i started to feel really guilty for
not speaking up because i had seen other
women speak up in other sports and i
knew this happened in skateboarding
more than just the one time it happened
to me it happened to me prior and i was
seeing it happen in other contests too
so
i felt guilty because i knew that being
in second place and there having been
money involved this is the type of story
people would listen to
and i did not expect it to blow up the
way that it did i thought it would cause
some local outrage and at least get a
conversation started since obviously
emailing red bull wasn't
a way to start a conversation about it
they did not want to have that
conversation at all
but um yeah it went viral and do you
think that um like moms
are like behind you
oh i get messages from parents all the
time there are so many parents who are
concerned about their kids and they have
young kids and they're concerned that
they're never going to get a fair
opportunity in sport or
might not even want to go try out for a
team if they're to face this
you think there's any value to having
like um elite a league where anyone can
compete men and women this is ridiculous
for like openly no i don't know an open
league that's correct i i don't think
that's like a ridiculous idea i think
that in some sports perhaps it could
work
but i don't think that it should be at
the cost of the female division i think
it's important for there to be a female
division
so why why aren't more people speaking
out because they're scared because they
saw what happened to me on the internet
but what you got like a job and you're
traveling yeah hello people like the
people who hate comment on my page i
don't know them they don't affect my
life at all i've been traveling the
world i got a new job i'm skating
literally as part of my job
thank you tim we got a bunch of skate
projects well so so full disclosure for
people listening you know we want to do
a skate shop we want to do contests we
want to do community events and i was
just like we need someone who's into
that stuff to like help make that happen
so you know taylor's gonna be working a
lot of that stuff aside from just being
in the vlog or whatever yeah yeah yeah
and you've seen him in a game of skate
is that i i've beat him in a bunch of
game escape but the thing is is he'll
only allow a camera and if he's already
yeah that's not true yeah so every time
you see it you gotta write a book about
that
he'll like invite nick down as soon as
he's got me to tease
something i i never invited anybody
but i really want people to understand
that if you speak up about this
you will get support
there's a lot of people who support you
and there might be a bit of an attack on
the internet at first and depending on
where you live people in your community
might treat you like garbage but do you
want to like sit around pretending that
you agree with them or would you rather
stand up for what's right
it's really hard for me to sit around
and act like it was okay i never saw you
respond out of anger to people i never
saw you like demean other people i've
only heard you talk about it in that how
you feel about what happened from the
beginning i said i don't want people to
go attack anyone i think that
the people who are responsible are the
contest organizers who allow it to
happen because the reality is all the
athletes competing are just going by the
rules
and i think that we just have to have an
honest conversation about
women deserving a fair space and what
can we do to create a solution that
everyone's happy with because what's
happening now is not fair and
there's a lot of people who are upset
about it i wouldn't my story wouldn't
have blown up if there weren't people
all over the world who are concerned
about what's going to happen to women's
sports if this continues well taylor
when you said you can sit around and
ignore it i was like oh that's what i
did like i remember when these
i would not consider myself by any means
transphobic or anti-trans in the
slightest and i would actually
i would tell people on the left who
don't want to speak up about these
issues that you really should speak up
about these issues because
when an issue on the left gets pushed so
far over the edge where we're talking
about surgery to kids where we're
talking about
women not being able to compete in
sports stuff like that right
by not talking about it what you're
essentially doing is you're taking the
most extreme version and now that's what
people think all trans people are right
all trans people are trying to you know
uh cut off your kids private parts and
then take your girls gold medal in track
and field or whatever
and
it's pushing more and more people to the
right because i remember
there would be stories about i think
when i was still doing a progressive
show is when fallon fox the transgender
mma fighter was just school in women
and i looked uh
beating beating the hell out of breaking
their skull
and i didn't want to cover it because i
i knew that i would get in trouble
but also
as like an mma fighter i was like i
don't think this is right and then i
would feel bad because i'm like but i'm
just uh i'm just a straight cis guy i
can't comment on it and we're just
creepy and yeah and we just want to talk
about it and i i didn't want to talk
about it yeah and
saying something that thought right
there that you would be like this seems
wrong but then divert you but i'm a
straight white man well yeah man i mean
when you're first of all and we can get
we can get vulnerable and not funny at
all where one like i have crippling
depression and anxiety and if i'm
surrounded by and i'm sure a lot of
people listening have felt this if
you're surrounded by people who will
belittle you because of those things
of course you're gonna think that it's
already a cult mentality
on top of me hating myself and having
imposter syndrome with whatever i do on
top of the fact that yeah i am kind of
like the enemy in that
terrain if someone just goes you're
speaking from privilege and my default
is to be down on myself anyway of course
i'm going to be like okay i guess i just
like shouldn't talk about it
this is the interesting thing here
between the two of you is that taylor
looked into the fire and just decided
one day to just jump through it
they grabbed you and threw you through
it they sure did
and then i was like we're gonna burn
them on the fire like wait it's not so
much of a fire as i thought it would
they thought they were putting you on
the pie or you're like wait i can see
through it i don't feel like it was so
much a choice for me either because at a
certain point i felt like i had to do
something and i was really frustrated
i was escorted
what was the
i
well i don't know i think i felt
it's hard to say
because i had a lot of friends who are
very supportive of me including like
mentors who have
been around throughout the years of me
skateboarding and
i just felt like i needed to do the
right thing and i knew that people would
come after me i knew that people would
come after me for being jewish being in
israel but also being in israel i felt
really safe i knew that there wasn't
going to be an angry mob with pitchforks
outside of my house no one was going to
attack me at the skate park although i
did have the experience where the the
guy i was renting from the day after i
went on piers morgan he like asked me to
leave
and i talked to him and i think it was a
misunderstanding plus there was a
language barrier
but um that was kind of scary i thought
for a second i messed my life up i'm
never going to be able to stay anywhere
but you communicated with him and
everything was fine yeah everything was
totally fine and we were cool after i
had someone throw me at skatepark
yeah i haven't had that happen at all in
real life i get threats online all day
but
i'm sure it could happen
that's very poignant that you mentioned
that communication with the person that
had misunderstood something they saw you
in yeah but i actually i don't even know
if he saw me or if he was just like why
is this woman bringing a camera crew
into the place i'm renting to her i'm
not part of this but everything was fine
and i've been i've been only support in
real life like it's been the opposite of
getting threatened at the skate park i
like go to a skate park in indiana and
everyone was high-fiving me excited i
was there well and what's really cool
about shows like this i think
is that
you know for a little while your only
option if you were thrown into the fire
by the left was to go full right wing
and that's what i refused to do even
when i was broke and in like a ratty
apartment infested with fleas like i did
not want to
do that what's really cool
about spaces like this is it
you just feel safe you just feel safe to
figure out how you feel and to evolve
and to ask questions and it doesn't mean
suddenly okay now i'm all right oh that
didn't work okay now i'm now i'm a
bernie bro oh that didn't work okay i'll
be a centrist m um you don't have to do
that you all of us
listening should be allowed to evolve
opinions without being called a grifter
should be allowed to agree with a
conservative thing here a liberal thing
here a progressive thing here um without
having to like you were talking about
before ian subscribe to a team because
for the most part if you find a team you
line up with entirely on every single
issue you're probably lying is what i've
found thanks for checking out this clip
from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8pm eastern
time super chat we'll even answer some
of your questions if you want to check
out the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you